la réussite est une chose essentielle et
en même temps ça fait reçoit finalement
la vie tout ça et fugitif en somme c'est
un but mais ce n'est pas je crois que en
effet permanent je me dis pourquoi tout
ça pour qui pourquoi jusque dans son
snack donc ce n'est quand même en de la
vie et ont très souvent la vie enfin dès
les années passent et on s'aperçoit que
peut être on a au détriment d'autres
choses on a sacrifié son temps mais
finalement que ce soit dans un an va
tout ce que j'ai fait j'ai été avec joie
et ma foi socialement socialement je
suis dans un milieu très parisien jeu
non je crois que ma vie sociale et je
suppose réussi en tout cas je la trouve
réussi ma vie de travail réussi ma vie
sentimentale également la eu des échecs
mais mais enfin par rapport à d'autres
je trouve que j'ai finalement dire j'ai
une vie d'une manière beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus vrai je suis un caractère
extrêmement droit et surtout très très
très imparfaite absolument à y aller et
je trouve que ma vie est une vie qui a
été à une vie de travail bien sûr
mehdi travail dans la joie et dans la
satisfaction par conséquent c'était un
loisir et d'amour et bien la mort qui
n'a peur de la mort mais je crois que l
étain et un instant enfin elle était
présente à tout moment qui demain
peut-être ce que demain je serai mort
veut d'être que je ferais écrasé ou 1 je
trouve que la mort est là c est un et
c'est une manière de ne plus être qui
qui est le sort de tous les individus
enfin vous y pensez
je n'y pense assez rarement jouée à dire
lorsque je vois autour de moi des
accidents de voiture ou où des êtres qui
me sont prêts ou que même des employés
enfin des choses qui sont plutôt
émouvantes comme par exemple pour un
détail de haute couture j'ai eu la
petite sainte catherine que j'ai coiffé
cette année est bien en surtemps de de
la fête que nous avons fait pour elle
elle est rentrée chez elle avec son
fiancé elle est morte sur le chemin du
retour
évidemment il est certain que dd
problème de cet ordre à toute échelle
tout de même parfois vous dise dans son
la ville très peu
enfin il fallait penser à la mort en
permanence pourquoi vivre et vous vous
préoccupez vous avez pensé à ce que
deviendrait notre président 90 e + 15
d'un coup je suis écouté j'ai formé des
cadres j'ai un jeune cara qui est tendre
l'hiver autour de moi qu'ils étaient
formés depuis 15 ans j'ai d'autres et
puma fois après moi et bien un dior
malheureusement est mort la maison
continue et puis quelle importance pour
moi qu'elle continuerait ne continue pas
je pense que le problème si je j'ai la
chance de vivre longtemps gens on aurait
tous les avantages si je disparais bien
la fois les autres en profiteront et mon
nom est certaine s'éteindra pas du jour
au lendemain il est trop vaste mais une
fois pour les multis façon je crois que
rien n'avait aucune solution dans ces
cas là
[Musique]